greatness is not this wonderful esoteric
illusive godlike feature that only the
special among us will ever taste you
know it's something that truly exists in
all of us do you have the mindset for
greatness
this isn't hokey fluffy bs advice if
you're laughing at this point or both
the close of video or think you know
better then you need this video more
than anyone else you're not hitting your
big goals and you click this video for a
reason so at least give yourself a
chance and finish it all the advice and
books in the world would be useless to
you until you fixed your mindset your
limiting mindset is holding you where
you are one of the most powerful ads
Nike has ever created doesn't feature
Michael Jordan or LeBron James it
pictures a chubby kid huffing and
puffing as he's running down an open
road
Nikes ads usually feature great athletes
physical specimens at the peak of their
careers who have already achieved
extraordinary success and here's this
fat kid running and he's great yes
because he took the first step he
started doing whoever made this ad for
Nike is a genius and needs a raise this
ad speaks directly to your mindset for
greatness when you're finding your
greatness you start at the beginning
everyone starts at the beginning and the
beginning is really hard just taking the
first step is hard maybe this kid wants
to be a distance runner and win an
Olympic medal he tells his friends and
family and they all laugh at him classic
little man behavior you wanna what have
you looked at yourself in the mirror
this fat kid is you you have a big goal
and you're just getting started on it
you don't have the skills you don't have
the training you don't have the
experience you don't have all the
answers
so you're going to make a lot of
mistakes and you won't make very much
progress right away
the difference is going to be how you
see yourself when you look in the mirror
do you honestly deep down see a future
Olympic runner or you just see a fat kid
if you just see a fat kid staring back
at you then you'll never reach your
goals until you change your mindset
maybe your first threat is only to the
edge of the driveway that's okay
most people put here it's too hard I'll
never make it what was I thinking man
this was a stupid idea
understand that every successful person
was once this fat kid when they got
started and as with any skill they've
learned practiced and got better
consistently they found their greatness
they didn't let the little man hold them
back they believed in themselves so they
succeeded what do you see in the mirror
if you see greatness you're ready for
your one word